my name is ramiah Krishnan I'm the
interim dean of the behind School of
Public Policy and management and it
gives me great pleasure to welcome you
all to this Hine stocks event via
delighted delighted and honored to host
this event in conjunction with the
presentation of this year's Heinz Awards
which is really a very important
occasion both in pittsburgh and in the
nation the award honors the achievement
of some impressive individuals who have
made a huge difference in their chosen
field or community and it's really quite
a wonderful and humbling experience for
me and for everybody involved to hear
about the wonderful things that these
people have accomplished I'm especially
pleased to welcome Teresa Heinz I was
here to listen to a discussion on a
subject which he cares deeply about and
has an abiding and well-informed
interest in it's a subject which most of
us are deeply concerned about as well
the task of the panel today as you know
is to give advice on climate change and
energy policy to the winner of the u.s.
presidential election it's very likely
that we will see some significant
efforts and changes in policy in this
area jeez I hope so this panel will
provide some thoughtful discussion of
this topic which is certainly going to
play an important role in our national
and global future it now gives me great
pleasure to introduce our moderator of
this evenings event dr. dr. Moyer gone
among other things she's actually while
at NASA worked on climate change models
dr. Gunn is the host of technician and
biotech nation which air in such venues
as the national public radio sirius
satellite radio channels NPR now in
Pierre talk and international leader
in 75 countries via the armed forces the
American forces radio international
technician is a seoul national weekly
radio program on the impact of
technology and its weekly biotech nation
segment enjoys the same status in the
area of biotech issues the intriguing
story of building biotech nation
building the biotech nation segment and
the leading issues facing us all in this
arena has described in our book welcome
to biotech nation my unexpected Odyssey
into the land of small molecules lean
genes and big ideas it is named to the
best science books of 2007 by the
American Library Association so without
further ado dr. Meyer again thank you
very much
thank you i am delighted to be here and
yes i am the host of technician and
biotech nation and several people
stopped me out in the in the hallway and
they said you know I listen to you on
podcasts while I'm working out and I
think if CM you can just get it science
going so I can passively benefit from
the calorie burning activity I would
really be appreciative and so for those
people who do listen I've already had a
couple of requests i can do it for
everybody at the same time it's the
opening line of the show from San
Francisco I'm Moira gun and this is
technician now my first duty here is a
distinct pleasure it's to introduce
Teresa Heinz and in so many want ways of
course Teresa needs no introduction of
course she is here today is the chairman
of the Heinz family philanthropies and
the Heinz and downs downman baumans
germane to our topic which is climate
change and energy policy advice to our
next president drea has worked
diligently on behalf of environmental
and ecological causes this includes the
establishment of the Heinz and awards
which includes a specific recognition
for the environment a mere few examples
of her personal efforts include being a
member of the official US delegation to
the United Nations conference on
environment and development in Brazil in
1992 since 1995 she has sponsored the
annual conference on women's health and
the environment mrs. Heinz has sponsored
such media productions as the
environment and the world eco minute
reaching citizens in more than a hundred
countries as well as the PBS produce
Health Week she serves on the advisory
council for the Center for children's
health and the environment in Mount
Sinai School of Medicine with her
husband Senator John Kerry she is
co-written the book this moment on earth
of this book the National Geographic
wrote this moment on earth makes demands
on its readers holding all of us
accountable for the environmental
implications of every decision whether
in Congress and state and local
government or in business
they say this is the moment not just to
talk about the planet but to save it now
this is certainly the committed and
public face of Teresa Heinz but is a
journalist is someone who interviews
people for a living we always want to
know who is this person really and so
first thing journalists do is they piece
together everything the resumes and the
background and it doesn't take too long
before you realized you know at some
point someone always comments isn't that
a record isn't she the only woman
married to US senators could this
possibly has anybody done it before well
I'm reminded of mrs. Jonas Salk I happen
to be standing next to her and a wildly
over-enthusiastic journalist was
standing in front of her and said why
mrs. sulk not only are you married to
the great man Jonas Salk but in fact
your first husband was Pablo Picasso
that is just incredible and he went on
and on and finally she said you find
that interesting it goes I find that
wildly interesting she said you find it
interesting that Lions sleep with lions
let me assure you Teresa Heinz is indeed
a lion and I knew it when I met her face
to face for the first time we go by that
in journalism we go by that certainly at
NPR where we see what used to be called
the measure of the man and now we say
the measure of the person because you
learn so much meeting them in person she
is a particular quality that I don't see
very often and I saw it very first
moment the last time i saw i was
thinking I've got to give you an example
just not give it a name the last time I
saw it I thought about a year ago when
dr. Muhammad Yunus walked into my studio
he of course is the the economist who
was the founder of Grameen Bank he
brought millions out of poverty and he
shared with the Grameen Bank the Nobel
Peace Prize there is a Nobel Prize in
Economics isn't there Lee yeah well
whatever it was a really great idea but
the truth is is that he walked into the
studio and immediately you could feel
the good
goodness coming out of every pore that
is what he is about and it was the same
quality that I encountered the very
first time that I met Teresa Heinz the
goodness was palpable and everything
she's done everything she does and has
ever since everything we're even doing
here today so please join me in
welcoming to the stage to race a Heinz
I should have flown in like an angel
thank you so much more and thank you for
being here all of you to hear a
distinguished panel and to hear John
Holdren it's a great pleasure to
introduce John with a professor her
researcher and educator and a friend of
many years who has been involved in many
of the most sensitive and complex
climate energy and nuclear arms issues
for more than three decades dr. Holdren
is the first recipient of the trailer
and John Hines the third chair in
environmental policy at Harvard School
kennedy school of government and deacon
currently serves as a director of the
Woods Hole Research Center interestingly
this chair was created soon after my
husband died in 91 and there was no one
to fill it for quite a while and it was
a chair that hoped to bring together I
know it wasn't 91 91 is at the Harvard
Business School to bridge business and
public policy so there was a chair
either on both of the schools and I had
nothing to do with John's appointment it
was a surprise for me at the one he was
finally stolen from Berkeley to Harvard
and they said we have a Dean I mean
edina a professor for your chair and
they told me it was John and I was
bowled over and I know my husband would
have been bowled over so he is that kind
of a person who just everything he
touches is his innocence blessed except
he has been able to do anything about
global climate change yet but he will he
will he traces his interest in energy
and arms control back to a book he read
while still in high school
Aaron Browns the challenge of man's
future which made the case that problems
of popular population food and energy
mineral resources and economic
development and international security
are not independent but intimately
intertwined so that solutions for all of
them must be pursued in parallel then a
young Holdren was persuaded and decided
that these interlocking
interdisciplinary problems of the human
condition pose the most interesting and
important challenges facing the modern
world he has been a member since 1973 of
the Pug wash conference on science and
world affairs an international group of
scholars and public figures who meet
regularly to discuss ways to reduce the
dangers from weapons of mass destruction
and to build international cooperation
on other common problems John has served
as a chairman of the executive committee
of per wash complaints from the 1987 to
97 and was chosen by his colleagues to
give the acceptance speech when the
organization share the Nobel Prize in
1995 world leaders continuously seek dr.
Holden's expertise and he has been
appointed to numerous national and
international committees to evaluate
energy strategies global environmental
problems and arms control from 94 to
2000 dr. Holdren served as the president
clinton's committee of advisors on
science and technology known as PCAST
dr. Holdren chaired the first study
request from PCAST which led to a 95
presidential decision directive revising
US policy on cooperation with Russia on
nuclear materials protection also in the
mid-90s he could share the National
Academy of Sciences reshaping of the
United States policy on the management
of this country's weapons-grade
plutonium and from nineteen ninety five
to nineteen ninety nine he chaired a
series of PCAST studies on revising US
energy research strategy to more
effectively address the challenges of
the 21st century including especially
the challenge of global climate change
John Holdren is that res scientist was
able to translate his research into
meaningful public policy he has applied
his interdisciplinary skills and
expertise in his extraordinaires
extraordinary intellect to improving
policies governing nuclear war arms
control climate change global
environmental degradation and resource
conservation simply put our world today
is safer and better off than it would
have been absent his contributions he is
joined by his wife dr. sherry Holdren
who was itself a distinguished scientist
and friend too and I welcome he John to
our town
well thank you very much Teresa it's a
delight to be here I'm going to start
with some remarks on the scientific
dimension of the challenges we face in
relation to energy and climate and that
will set the stage I think for remarks
to follow by Professor Granger Morgan
and professor Lee Branstetter on
technological and economic and public
policy dimensions of this question and
then comments by a hind school master of
science student Melissa young who will
comment I think on the whole array of
issues that confront us in this domain
all of this under the title of advice on
Energy and Climate Change for the next
president I would start by saying that
the single most important thing that the
next president of the United States
needs to understand about the energy
climate challenge is that that challenge
is not less important than the economy
it is not less important than national
security it is intertwined with those
other crucial ingredients of our
well-being and in a very fundamental way
the essence of the matter is this
without energy there is no economy
without climate there is no environment
without economy and environment there is
no material well-being there is no civil
society there is no personal security or
national security or international
security and the essence of the problem
is that the world has long been getting
the energy that its economy needs from
burning fossil fuels that have been
releasing greenhouse gases destroying
the climate that its environment needs
compounding that predicament tropical
developing countries have been busy
chewing up their rainforests under a
misguided economics that
makes consumption of environmental
capital for income that adds more carbon
dioxide to the atmosphere than all of
the cars trucks buses trains and
airplanes in the world and that is
rapidly depleting the greatest
storehouse of biodiversity on the planet
this has all got to be fixed and it's
got to be fixed fast global warming the
next president also needs to understand
is a misnomer it's a wholly misleading
term whose popular use as a description
of what's happening to the climate has
probably delayed the appropriate sense
of urgency by a decade or more the word
global suggests something that's uniform
across the planet and warming suggests
that it's mainly about temperature that
it's happening gradually and for many
might even be welcome the reality is
different what's happening is highly non
uniform geographically with the largest
amounts of heating taking place mid
continent and in the far north it's not
just about temperature but about
humidity soil moisture patterns of
precipitation storm tracks ocean
currents and all the other phenomena
that constitute climate the changes are
not gradual but rapid by the two
standards that matter the most rapid
compared to the rate at which ecosystems
can adapt and rapid compared to the rate
at which human societies can adapt and
while these changes in climate might
benefit some people in some places for
some period of time for most people in
most places and starting sooner rather
than later the changes are going to
entrain far more harm than good rather
than calling it global warming we should
be calling it global climate disruption
the year round globally average surface
temperature of the earth which
climatologists track as an index of the
state of the climate is going up the
earth is heating up albeit in fits and
starts because of the complexity of the
interacting
natural and human influences upon it but
it's important to understand that the
change in that index the change in the
global average surface temperature does
not in itself constitute a description
of the associated disruption the earth's
surface temperature as an index of the
state of the climate is like the
temperature of your body as an index of
how the bottling machinery is working in
both cases relatively small changes in
the index correspond to big changes in
the condition of the system if your body
temperature goes up 5.4 degrees
Fahrenheit that is three degrees Celsius
from 98.6 Fahrenheit to 104 Fahrenheit
that reflects complex and dangerous
disruptions going on in your body
everybody understands that everybody
understands that that sort of increase
in body temperature calls for consulting
a physician and quickly well the average
surface temperature of the earth is a
similarly sensitive indicator an
increase of three degrees Celsius 5.4
degrees Fahrenheit would be associated
with profound changes in climatic
patterns it would correspond to a severe
fever of the earth and it calls for
consulting specialists and doing
something about it illustrative of this
we know that the difference in global
average surface temperature between an
ice age and the sort of warm
interglacial that we've been enjoying
for about the last twelve thousand years
is just five degrees Celsius nine
degrees Fahrenheit and in fact with the
average surface temperature having risen
now in the last hundred years only about
eight tenths of a degree Celsius 1.4
degrees Fahrenheit we are already
observing substantial disruption of
climatic patterns from their long-term
norms the science relating to the main
features of this phenomenon is about as
unequivocal as science gets it's not
only telling us that the disruption is
real and that it's caused mostly by
human
rather than by natural climatic
variation it's also telling us that the
disruption is already creating
significant harm to the well-being of
societies and ecosystems across the
planet and it's telling us that the
disruption is accelerating and the harm
escalating faster than seemed plausible
to almost anybody a decade ago or even
five years ago civilizations emissions
of carbon dioxide are growing faster
than the highest growth scenarios that
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change put forth in 2001 the carbon
dioxide concentration of the atmosphere
is likewise rising faster than projected
due both to the rising emissions and to
apparent slowdowns in the uptake of part
of the carbon dioxide in the oceans and
in northern forests and soils the rates
of increase of temperature and sea level
are at the high end of the ranges of the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change 2001 projections sea level is now
increasing at twice the average rate
that it did in the 20th century the
floating sea ice that covers most of the
Arctic Ocean which a few years ago
experts thought might disappear by 2070
in a steadily heating world has been
shrinking so rapidly that the same
experts now say it could be gone by 2013
or 2015 as for escalating harm to human
well-being the harm that is already
occurring floods droughts heat waves and
wildfires have all been increasing in
the respective parts of the world
already prone to those syndromes and in
patterns that climate change models
predicted would result from greenhouse
gas induced climatic disruption changes
in the monsoons in India and China are
already impacting food production in
both of those countries tropical
pathogens are expanding their ranges
their geographic ranges and pest
outbreaks tied to altered climatic
conditions are ravaging both temperate
and boreal forests the formerly moist
tropical forests rain forests that were
once too wet
to burn are now a fire every two or
three years destroying timber and
launching more carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere to amplify the greenhouse
effect the world's coral reefs are being
poached in the warming surface seas and
they're being pickled by increased
acidity caused when some of the
atmospheres excess carbon dioxide
dissolves in seawater and forms carbonic
acid livelihoods dependent on the coral
reefs the second greatest reservoir of
biodiversity on the planet after the
tropical forests are at risk the
evidence is strong that the intensifying
warming of surface waters is also
intensifying the most severe tropical
storms the ones we call typhoons in the
western Pacific and hurricanes in the
eastern Pacific and in the Atlantic the
World Health Organization not prone to
exaggeration in these matters estimated
in 2002 that climate change was killing
upwards of a hundred and fifty thousand
people per year already in the year 2000
the casualties of increased floods
droughts heat waves and the climate
related growth of tropical diseases the
World Health Organization is working on
an estimate for 2005 which will
undoubtedly be higher than the 150,000
per year it estimated for two thousand
and we're heading for worse without
sharp changes in civilizations
trajectory of greenhouse gas emissions
from the energy system and from tropical
deforestation the global average surface
temperature is going to soar from eight
tenths of a degree above the 1750 level
in 2005 22 degrees Celsius above in 2050
and three degrees Celsius above in 2100
the last time the world was as warm as
we're headed for being in 2050 was a
hundred and thirty thousand years ago
and sea level then was four to six
meters that is 13 to 20 feet higher than
it is today the last time the world was
as warm as were headed for being in 2100
if we don't change course was 30 million
years ago in the
eocene when my Harvard colleague Dan
schrag likes to say there were
crocodiles swimming off of Greenland and
palm trees in Wyoming and sea level then
was 20 to 30 meters that is 66 to 98
feet higher than sea level is today now
it takes centuries for sea level to
reach equilibrium with higher
temperatures but nobody knows how many
centuries our models are still
inadequate to reflect the processes that
can produce rapid disintegration of the
great ice sheets on Antarctica and
Greenland and we simply do not know how
fast sea level could rise we do know
that rates of increase as high as 2 to 5
meters per century have accompanied
natural warming periods in the past and
that should be scary facing this
situation society has only three options
mitigation the measures you take to
reduce the pace and the magnitude of the
climate changes that occur adaptation
the measures you take to reduce the
impacts of climate changes that you fail
to avoid things like developing heat
resistant drought resistant and salt
resistant crops building more dams and
dikes changing habitation patterns to
move away from seacoast and so on and
the third option we have to be clear
about this is suffering those are the
three mitigation adaptation and
suffering we're already doing some of
all three we're doing some mitigation
we're doing some adaptation and we're
doing some suffering what's up for grabs
in this issue is the future mix of those
how much mitigation how much adaptation
and how much suffering we know we can't
rely on mitigation alone because climate
change is already well underway and
nothing we do can stop it in its tracks
we can't rely on adaptation alone
because adaptation gets more difficult
more costly and less effective the
bigger are the changes in climate to
which you're trying to adapt how does a
low-lying island state adapt to 2 meters
of sea level rise
that's not adaptation it's evacuation
what we need to do is to apply enough
mitigation to avoid climatic changes too
large to adapt to this was summarized in
the subtitle of a UN report with which I
was associated on climate change in
sustainable development the subtitle was
avoiding the unmanageable and managing
the unavoidable avoiding the
unmanageable that's mitigation managing
the unavoidable that's adaptation and to
the extent we fail to do enough of both
make no mistake we will suffer with
respect to the question of how much
mitigation is needed and how fast in
order to avoid the unmanageable it's
important to note that the official goal
of the UN Framework Convention on
Climate Change to which the United
States and a hundred and ninety other
countries are parties was to avoid
dangerous human interference in the
climate system and the sad news is that
goal is already out of reach it has
already lost because by any reasonable
definition of the word dangerous we are
already experiencing dangerous human
interference in the climate system if a
hundred and fifty thousand excess deaths
per year in the year 2000 was not
already dangerous I don't know what is
the question before us now is whether we
can avoid catastrophic human
interference in the climate system the
best chance for doing that requires
stabilizing the sum of all the human
influences on the atmosphere at the
equivalent of 450 parts per million of
carbon dioxide or less to do that
requires that the overall emissions of
greenhouse gases and other climate
altering substances worldwide need to
peak no later than 2020 and be declining
there after allowing a reasonable amount
of additional growth in the developing
countries means that the industrialized
nations must level off their green
gas emissions and begin to decline no
later than about 2015 so that the
developing countries can have until
about 20-25 to level off and begin to
decline and it's important to understand
some of the dynamics of this problem
that make it so difficult one can
summarize some of those difficult
dynamics by pointing out that
stabilizing emissions does not stop the
growth of concentrations if we leveled
off emissions where they are today the
concentrations in the atmosphere would
continue to rise stabilizing
concentrations doesn't stop the growth
of temperature because after you
stabilize concentrations it takes the
oceans decades to catch up with the
changes you've imposed on the atmosphere
we are already experiencing today only
something in the range of sixty percent
of the temperature increase that would
ultimately be associated with what we
have already done to the atmosphere if
we could stop the rise of concentration
instantaneously temperatures would coast
up about another half a degree Celsius
and finally stabilizing temperature
doesn't stop the growth of the damages
after you stabilize temperature at a
higher value the ice will continue to
melt for thousands of years continuing
to raise sea level so there are huge
time lags built into the response of the
system and we further have to confront
the time lags in the human system the
energy system which is responsible for a
large fraction of the emissions that are
altering our climate is very expensive
very large very slow to change today's
energy system represents in the world an
investment of about 15 trillion dollars
in capital that's what it would cost you
to replace all the power plants oil
refineries pipelines transmission lines
drilling rigs in the world 15 trillion
dollars and that 15 trillion dollar
investment which by the way is today
eighty percent in fossil fuel energy
systems and technologies eighty percent
of the world's energy comes from coal or
and natural gas for all you hear about
nuclear energy and solar and geothermal
80% coming from coal oil and natural gas
eighty percent in round numbers of that
fifteen trillion dollar investment is
tied up in the technologies that are
wrecking the climate and that investment
work nearly turns over in about 40 years
that's the average lifetime of a power
plant and oil refinery and what have you
if you want the energy system in 2050 to
look very different from the energy
system today you got to start changing
it now the other big component of the
problem deforestation is also hard to
change deforestation is driven by forces
that are deeply embedded in the
economics of development of timber of
fuel of trade we can't change it
overnight no matter what we do but
change it we must so what we need to do
what does the next president need to be
thinking about in terms of what needs to
be done this is largely going to be
addressed by my colleagues I love it
when I lay out a difficult problem and
then say my colleagues will give you the
answer I will say a few quick things
about what is needed and then leave them
to flush it out number one there are
some win-win solutions out there things
we can do that address climate change
but also make money or address other
development goals reduce conventional
pollution reduce oil dependence and so
on those so-called win-win solutions are
not being embraced at the pace they
ought to be because they're a variety of
barriers out there to embracing them
perverse incentives subsidies of the
wrong things tax incentives that go in
the wrong direction and so on we need to
knock those barriers down secondly we
need to put a price on greenhouse gas
emissions we need to make it expensive
to put these greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere this is probably the single
most important thing we can do we could
do it with a cap-and-trade approach we
could do it with a tax one way or the
other we have to make it expensive third
we have to apply some supplementary
measures to the price on greenhouse gas
emissions to deal with particularly
difficult sectors with coal-fired
electricity generation to create
incentives large enough that coal-fired
power plants will capture their carbon
die
oxide rather than admitting it to the
atmosphere and sequester it away from
the atmosphere we need to increase
investments in energy technology
research development and demonstration
by several fold in the public sector and
we need to increase the incentives for
private sector research to improve
energy technologies that we will need to
address these challenges in a
cost-effective way I sometimes say that
the things we can do that a win-win that
already make money or like the
low-hanging fruit but we need energy
research and development to lower some
of the higher hanging fruit and bring it
in to reach and we need a price on
greenhouse gas emissions to motivate
reaching higher into the tree we need to
expand partnerships public private and
international for deploying advanced
energy technologies because this is a
problem that has to be solved everywhere
not just in a few countries but all
around the world and we need to achieve
a new global agreement for mitigation
and adaptation in the post 2012 period
aimed at declining global emissions by
2020 and including compensation to
tropical forest nations for not cutting
down there for us if we don't pay them
to not cut down there for us they're all
going to be cut down and so on that
happy note I'm going to turn it over to
my colleagues to give you the details of
how we're going to fix this and then our
student member will respond with cries
of outrage that we created such a mess
for her generation to deal with thank
you very much
thank you dr. John Holdren thank you
very much now art our next fixer put in
the fix here and our next fixer is dr.
Granger Morgan he's professor and head
of the department of engineering and
public policy here at CMU where he's
also University and Lord share professor
in engineering in addition he holds
academic appointments in the Department
of Electrical and Computer Engineering
and in the h john hines the third school
of public policy and management his
research addresses problems in science
technology in public policy with
particular focus on energy environmental
systems climate change and risk analysis
at Carnegie Mellon dr. Morgan directs
the National Science Foundation's
climate decision-making center and
co-directs the Carnegie Mellon
electricity industry Center he served as
chair of the Science Advisory Board of
the US Environmental Protection Agency
and as chair of the Advisory Council of
the electrical power research institute
among his distinctions dr. Morgan is a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences and a fellow of the American
Association for the Advancement of
science please join me in welcoming dr.
Granger Morgan
thanks very much well john told you that
energy is a big part of the problem and
so i'm going to talk a bit about how we
might begin to reduce carbon emissions
from the energy system in fact we have
to reduce them by something like eighty
percent or more because unlike
conventional pollutants sulfur dioxide
oxides of nitrogen which stay in the
atmosphere for just a few hours or a day
or two carbon dioxide stays in the
atmosphere for as much as a century or
more and so it's like a big bathtub
that's as though we had an enormous
faucet and a relatively small drain and
unless we close the faucet down
dramatically the bathtub is just going
to continue to fill up so we got to
figure out how do we close that faucet
and energy is a big part of the answer
now energy is in fact energy systems are
the largest source of carbon dioxide
just under forty percent comes from
generating electricity about thirty
percent comes from transportation and
buildings which of course overlap those
two constitute about half of all co2
emissions so that tells us where to
focus I'm going to talk about four
things I'm going to talk about using
electricity more efficiently I'm going
to talk about making sure that new
buildings are much more energy efficient
I'm going to talk about converting to
carbon-free electricity and I'm going to
wrap up with a word or two about
reducing emissions from motor vehicles
so let's start with energy efficiency
first thing to note is that this doesn't
mean that we have to suffer I mean it
does mean we have to use less energy but
we can get the goods and services that
we're used to if we're smart and we use
energy more effectively the best way to
demonstrate that for starters is to look
at a country like Denmark how many of
you been in Denmark but you know life
there is not that tough the US uses
dramatically more energy both per person
and per GDP than Denmark
Denmark uses about forty five percent as
much energy per person about fifty
percent as much energy per GDP produced
so that's one example that says we
there's a long way we could go by simply
adopting some of the things that others
around the world are already doing I'll
give you a couple of examples the first
one is appliance standards now back in
the 1970s a average refrigerator was 18
cubic feet today it's 22 cubic feet
that's a twenty-two percent increase in
size back then it cost about a thousand
dollars today it costs four hundred and
sixty dollars that's about a fifty five
percent decrease in cost now here's the
zinger today refrigerators use
sixty-eight percent less electricity
than they did back in the 70s why
because of appliance standards first
developed in California and then
subsequently adopted by at a national
level so we could do the same sort of
things for lots of other technologies
like the big flat-screen TVs that are
power hogs power supplies and lots of
other things and so on there's many
opportunities for appliance standards
that we have not yet used lighting uses
about twenty percent of all electric
power and new solid-state lighting that
uses LEDs light emitting diodes is just
under ten times as much as efficient in
terms of the amount of light produced as
incandescent bulbs and it it does at the
moment about as well as fluorescence but
unlike fluorescence which aren't getting
substantially more efficient solid-state
lighting is rapidly getting more
efficient now it is more expensive at
this stage but the problem with
incandescent bulbs is that while they're
cheap they don't last very long a few
hundred to a few thousand hours
solid-state light last 30,000 to 50,000
dyers so once you bought one you pretty
much got it forever and in life cycle
terms with
commercial discount rates solid-state
lighting is already a good buy policies
that could be put in place could promote
this in residential and other sectors as
well and the last thing I want to talk
about on on the efficiency front is per
capita use across the country now the US
has seen constant growth in per capita
electricity consumption actually linear
not exponential but still it's been
growing in contrast for the past 20
years or so California and New York have
been flat in terms of per capita
consumption of electricity and Vermont
is actually seen slightly falling per
capita consumption now why it's not
because they were just sitting back and
doing nothing all three of those states
have had aggressive programs to promote
a wide range of efficient technologies
Vermont for example skins a little bit
of money off every kilowatt hour sold
puts it into a pool which is then used
to promote all kinds of energy efficient
activities all around the state so
that's the first topic energy efficiency
the second topic I'll be briefer about
this is new buildings my colleague
Lester lave tells me that new both
commercial and residential buildings
could be seventy to eighty percent more
energy efficient than current standard
buildings and he points to examples of
homes in California and Florida where
some were made energy-efficient some
were pretty standard and in fact that is
the kind of difference that's being
observed now you know there may be some
behavioral differences presumably the
people who bought the energy-efficient
buildings were also look you know they
were conscious of this issue but but the
bottom line is that we could have
dramatic impacts how well with various
building codes and standards that insist
that we for example use to buy six
rather than to buy for construction that
we use good insulation and so on third
thing I want to talk about is converting
to clean sources of electricity now
everybody talks about solar and solar
thermal for water heating can be cost
effective today and in some parts of the
solar thermal for electricity is getting
pretty cost-effective unfortunately
solar photovoltaics or PV is at least
six times too expensive and in a recent
study we did Amy Courtright who's
sitting out here and i did with 18
leading pv experts it looks like it's
going to be many decades before it's
going to become cost effective for bulk
power electricity even in places like
electricity we need to spend money on
research that is on improving the
efficiency of cells on power electronics
on batteries but it probably doesn't
make sense to pour great gobs of public
money into deploring deploying the
current generation of technology because
the learning curves are just not steep
enough we can talk more about that
during the discussion cessive and if
you're interested but in contrast to
solar wind is today quite cost
competitive with other sources of carbon
free energy in the main problem of
course with both wind and solar power is
that it's intermittent and to cover the
gaps we're going to need something else
typically these days that means gas
turbines and when they get cycled up and
down they produce co2 but they also
produce lots of NOx New Jersey is a good
example New Jersey has a renewable
portfolio standard that's going to
require a significant amount of
renewables the obvious thing to put in
is wind but New Jersey also has a
serious Knox problem and so this problem
can get solved but to date the folks who
design turbines have not really given it
the attention it deserves and I want to
wrap up this section on renewables with
a warning it's really important to do
analysis before setting targets
Pennsylvania's politicians have
implemented a requirement for 800
megawatts of solar PV and my colleague
Jay apt has estimated that between now
and the year 2020 that's going to cost
Pennsylvania ratepayers 1.8 billion
dollars more than the same amount of
wind and then after that about 400
million dollars every year thereafter so
while renewables can help they aren't
going to get us to the eighty percent
reduction by mid-century that John
talked about and that
I endorse and that means we're going to
look for other things nuclear is great
but nuclear is only twenty percent of
current generation my own view is that
will be really lucky if we can keep it
at that fraction because there are lots
of problems as we all know inciting and
built building new nuclear plants today
just over half of our electricity comes
from coal of the fraction bounces a bit
and coal as it's used today is dirty
nasty stuff given the way its mind and
used but I don't see any other way to
get an eighty percent reduction without
substantial use of coal with carbon
capture and sequestration that is the
notion that either before or after you
burn the stuff you capture the carbon
dioxide you put it a kilometer or more
underground in a in a secure reservoir
where it will stay more or less
indefinitely now we've done in my
department a lot of technical work on
this if you're interested we also have a
couple million dollar effort going on
right now on developing a regulatory
framework for ccs it's really easy to
remember how to go see it it's wwcc s
rig org the bottom line is there are no
magic bullets it's going to take
everything we got in terms of
decarbonizing the electricity system so
how fast could we do it and what might
it cost a couple of years ago for the
Pew Center we did a an analysis of the
electricity system if you doubled the
rate at which we now build new plants
and you only put in carbon free
generation we would completely
decarbonize the electricity system in
about 50 years and you say wha but isn't
that going to be enormously expensive
yeah it'll be expensive and if you do it
overnight of course it'll break the bank
but if you do it in the sort of orderly
way i just described the cost will be
about comparable to what it costs this
industry to meet the requirements of the
Clean Air Act you know everybody said
meeting the Clean Air Act is going to
erect the economy it didn't and in my
view decarbonizing the electricity
system will also be entirely manageable
if we get started now we do it in a
system
orderly way last thing I want to say
just a word or two about is
transportation now the obvious way to
deal with emissions from Motor Vehicles
is to dramatically improve gas mileage
and we've had in this country for quite
a few years this initiative freedom car
that promised a hydrogen future they
sort of held this Mirage out there on
the horizon my own view is that that was
basically a strategy to allow the auto
industry not to do anything not to do
all the things that we technically knew
how to do by promising this wonderful
future well of course it hasn't turned
out that way and now we're stuck with a
fleet that's that's still using lots and
lots of gasoline much more than ought to
be than not to use given the
technologies we have in hand ethanol
from corn is basically just a giant farm
subsidy program biomass fuels from
cellulose things like switchgrass wood
chips and so on and maybe also from
trash may be able to play a role but the
indirect impacts on food prices and on
land use are still only now being
understood and and in my view probably
going to be a serious limit hybrids can
help but they are only a part of the
solution smaller lighter cars and much
more efficient conventional gas engines
clearly are needed and plug electric
hybrids may be useful but not so much to
address the carbon problem I mean if
you're worried about that straight
hybrids do almost as well butt plug
electric hybrids as you start to
decarbonize the electricity system may
be an important part of getting
ourselves weaned off of imported oil so
we got to ask for one piece of advice
for the new administration and I've been
told I'm not supposed to give it until
the very end but since John violated the
rule I will too we need to stop thinking
and talking and start investing and
putting people to work developing new
low carbon energy technology for example
if we don't stop talking and start
building some commercial scale CCS
plants carbon capture and sequestration
plants the technology transfer that a
lot of people have talked about being
from the u.s. to China is going to be in
the other direction because there's lots
of folks in China actively aggressively
developing this stuff and they're going
to get way down the learning curve
before we even get started they're going
to know how to do it and we won't and if
we don't get really serious about
research on batteries renewables and
hybrids may never see their full
potential we don't get serious about
improving dramatically the energy
efficiency of new buildings will condemn
ourselves to another 50 to 80 years of
much higher energy use continued co2
emissions and continued dependence on
imported oil and gas thanks
thank you dr. Granger Morgan and
actually it's not that you can't have
any recommendation advice for the
president but at the very end you get a
final last word in case you weren't
listening to me here's my final piece of
advice but we've heard from engineering
and now it's time to hear from economics
Lee branstetter is associate professor
of economics and public policy at
carnegie mellon university's h john
hines the third school of public policy
and management he came to the Heinz
school in 2006 from the Columbia
Business School where he was the Daniel
Staten associate professor of business
and director of the international
business program dr. brands debtors
research interests include international
economics the economics of technological
innovation industrial organization East
Asian economic group and the Japanese
economy he's an associate editor of the
journal of international economics and a
faculty research fellow at the national
bureau of economic research among his
other courses at the hynes school he
teaches the economics of global warming
please join me in welcoming dr. Lee
bronsted er
well I'm very glad that John Holdren and
his remarks noted that perhaps the most
important thing we can do to address the
global warming problem is to put a price
on greenhouse gas emissions now I'm
going to talk about how that can happen
in the context of a cap-and-trade system
but before I get into that I want to
take just one minute to acknowledge the
memory and legacy of a heinz family
member who served on the faculty of the
hind school for several years before
illness tragically claimed her life
professor penny Ferrara was passionately
devoted to educating Hines school
students about environmental issues in
general and this issue of climate change
in particular now she's no longer with
us but we at the high end school have
not forgotten the cause as to which she
was so deeply devoted in her life and
our engagement in this panel our efforts
to build new courses in this area are
now growing presence in DC are all part
of our efforts to ensure that her
passion and her vision gets transmitted
not just to the current generation of
high school students but those who will
follow after them we will never forget
professor penny Ferrara her legacy of
the hind school lives on now I'm here as
an economist and I want to tell you that
the global warming problem is a classic
example of market failure and here's how
the market fails when we engage in
activities that emit greenhouse gases
we're contributing to a growing
atmospheric stock of greenhouse gases
that will if unchecked eventually caused
tens of trillions of dollars of economic
damages around the world but the price
we pay today for the emitting activities
we engage in does not reflect the future
cost of this environmental damage now in
a market system people in firms respond
to prices we need to intervene in the
market in a way that forces people to
pay a price for the environmental damage
they caused and a cap-and-trade system
is one way to do that notre a
cap-and-trade system the government sets
an overall target of greenhouse gas
emissions for the economy at a point in
time this is the cap the total level of
permitted greenhouse gas emissions then
the government distributes the right to
emit bits of this national total to
firms in the form of emissions permits
and allows firms to trade these permits
among themselves firms with fewer
emissions than expected can effectively
sell
access permits to firms that are
generating more emissions and they have
permits and the price at which these
permits trade will effectively impose a
price on emissions now initially this
price is imposed on firms of course but
it gets passed on to consumers so that
everyone has to pay a price for the
environmental damage they caused and
that gives them an economic incentive to
minimize the damage now over time the
government steadily tightens the cap it
lowers the total amount of permitted
emissions and this calls the price this
causes the price of emission permits to
rise hopefully in a steady predictable
way people pay a higher and higher price
for emissions and the economic
incentives to reduce emissions get
steadily stronger now economist's like
cap-and-trade systems because they allow
forms a great deal of flexibility in
responding to these incentives economist
speak of this flexibility in terms of
how flexibility where flexibility and
when flexibility how flexibility refers
to the fact that firms have the freedom
to lower emissions however they can
achieve the most cheaply I mean at some
level we really don't care how the
emissions are achieved so long as they
are achieved and firms can respond to
these incentives by adopting new
technology or they can use existing
technology more carefully or they can
change the business they're in now in
contrast forcing all firms to reduce
emissions by adopting a particular
technological approach could be quite
costly for some farms now let's talk
about where flexibility some firms and
industries in the economy will be able
to reduce their emissions more cheaply
than others as caps tighten and permit
prices rise firms that can reduce
emissions cheaply and efficiently get a
greater and greater cost advantage over
firms that cannot because firms that
cannot have to keep on buying lots of
expensive permits now this gives low
emission firms and incentive to reduce
their emissions as much as they can so
they maximize their cost advantage and
as that cost advantage gets bigger the
low emission firms tend to dominate
their industries slowly squeezing out
the high emission guys with cap and
trade we don't have to hope that our
government is smart enough to figure out
where the low-cost emissions reduction
opportunities are the market will find
it for us and concentrate emissions
reductions in the firms and industries
where they can be reduced most cheaply
and efficiently now this where
flexibility is considerably limited if
we have a cap-and-trade system that
covers only part of the economy
let's say you impose a cap-and-trade
style regulation on electric power
generation but ignore the rest of the
economy well as you tighten caps
emissions reductions will tend to be
concentrated in the electric power
plants that can do it more cheaply but
your search for relatively cheap
emissions reductions opportunities is
limited to just one sector you could be
missing a lot the most efficient power
plant in the country may still find it
more costly to reduce emissions than
that widget factory in Kansas but you've
cut off your ability to shift the
emissions reduction burden to that
widget factory so to maximize where
flexibility you need to cover as much of
the economy as possible and of course if
the cap and trade system covers not just
one country but dozens of countries then
the opportunities for finding relatively
inexpensive ways of reducing total
emissions probably goes up even further
most economists would see a us-only
cap-and-trade system as a stepping stone
toward a system that would include
multiple countries thereby maximizing
the where flexibility in the system and
then there's when flexibility we
obviously want to start reducing
emissions very soon and we need to start
reducing emissions very soon but if
emissions could be reduced next year
much more cheaply than they can be
reduced this year then we would probably
want to shift some of our reductions to
next year now sophisticated
cap-and-trade systems provide for
flexibility over time they allow firms
to bank excess emissions permits today
for future use or borrow them from
future our future allocations repaying
these loans with interest but even
without this feature firms have a choice
of paying for form for permits in the
short run if it's too costly to change
their business practices but investing
in abatement technologies in the longer
run so that they don't have to keep
buying so many expensive permits and
this flexibility in adjustment over time
can be extremely important today almost
everything about our economy is
optimized for an emission price of zero
because we've not tried to price in the
environmental damage our emissions
create our cars are too big our houses
are insufficiently insulated in the list
goes on now if we try to force the
economy to become totally efficient
overnight we did impose immense costs on
the economy and giving ourselves a
little bit of time can lower the costs a
lot but this is not just an adjustment
costs argument if firms know that caps
will tighten and permits will become
steadily more expensive
then they will start investing a lot in
green technologies and the technologies
that will be available to reduce
emissions tomorrow are likely to be much
better than the technologies that we
have available today further lowering
the economic costs of trans of
transition to a low-carbon economy now
the how where and when flexibility of a
cap-and-trade system convers an
important advantage at least in theory
over traditional methods of
environmental regulation it can be
tempting for governments to try to
reduce emissions by forcing businesses
or customers to adopt or consumers to
adopt certain technologies products or
practices and sometimes this can work
but can also dramatically raised the
economic costs of reducing emissions in
some contexts now let me give you an
illustrative example it's not meant to
be you know necessarily accurate but
illustrator let's say that we passed a
new law that requires that every new car
sold in America has to get at least 50
miles to the gallon now one level this
would be good for the climate as well as
good for saving gas because the less
fuel a car burns per mile the less co2
it adds to the atmosphere to Pearl I'll
so that sounds pretty good right but
wait a minute the new cars get 50 miles
per gallon but these new cars could be
very expensive too expensive for some
families in America to afford so this
policy actually gives less affluent
Americans a strong incentive to hold on
to their old gas guzzlers as long as
possible even if the new cars get very
good gas mileage the average gas mileage
of the national vehicle fleet could stay
pretty low perhaps her a very long time
and the new regulations would not give
drivers of cars new or old any incentive
to drive their cars less if average
miles per gallon goes up but average
vehicles per car per year go up even
more if everyone drives their cars a lot
more than emissions go up and not down
and finally a sky high mileage standard
for cars does nothing to limit emissions
generated by electricity plants or
construction companies it ignores the
roughly seventy-five percent of
greenhouse gas emissions generated
outside the transportation sector now
this is a somewhat artificial example
but it illustrates a real problem
according to one study undertaken by
resources for the future using
sector-specific technology mandates
like fuel efficiency standards for new
cars to reduce emissions instead of an
economy-wide cap-and-trade program could
raise the economic costs of reducing
those emissions by a factor of ten a
factor of 10 and this report isn't
coming from lobbyists for the auto
industry resources for the future is
perhaps the most respected environmental
think tank in DC if not the world so for
all these reasons cap-and-trade seems
like a reasonable place to start if we
want to get serious about climate change
but getting it to work well requires
that we get the details right first we
need a cap-and-trade system that covers
as much of the greenhouse gas emitted
economy as possible there'll be a strong
political push to exempt industries from
the system and we need to resist those
efforts second we need a cap-and-trade
system with a safety valve now what do I
mean well let's say that we have a
really cold winter which requires us to
heat our houses more than normal
followed by a really hot summer which
requires us to air-condition our houses
more than normal and in the midst of
this we have a nun anticipate echinata
spaded economic boom well demand for
energy is going to go up relative to
everyone's forecasts and to meet all
this demand for energy use companies
throughout the economy will be competing
for a limited number of permits to a
much greater degree than they or the
government anticipated the price of
these permits could go way way up very
very quickly energy-intensive industries
would struggle to deal with a sharp
spike and permit prices and in the short
run the only feasible response might be
to lay off workers and curtail
operations and if our energy intensive
industries are competing with industries
overseas that you not face a similarly
rising carbon price then they may lose
market share now this is where the
safety valve kicks in if the price of
permits spikes then a price ceiling
kicks in and firms are able to buy as
many permits as they need at that
ceiling price now the downside is that
actual emissions could exceed the cap
under extraordinary circumstances but it
prevents permit prices from spiking and
then collapsing in the next year and if
we want strong stable incentives for
businesses to invest in green technology
then we need to limit permit price
volatility a safety valve helps
accomplish that third we need a
cap-and-trade system which moves towards
auctioning off permits to the highest
bidder as quickly as possible most
existing cap-and-trade systems have
handed permits to regulated firms for
free
now this cushions the negative impact of
the cap on emitting industries but even
with fairly modest caps the market value
of emissions permits in the u.s. could
be worth tens of billions of dollars per
year and it's definitely not
economically optimal in the long run to
keep giving away an asset this valuable
to emitting industries for nothing by
auctioning off permits of the highest
bidder the government could raise
significant amounts of tax revenue and
you could use this revenue to reduce
other taxes to compensate vulnerable
households or invest in green
technologies or you could do some of all
three most economists would strongly
recommend an allocation system that
moves to 100% auctions as quickly as
politically possible now is a cap and
trade system enough by itself to achieve
meaningful reductions and us emissions
probably not economic research suggests
that the free market will invest way too
little in basic research even if we
assigned a price to emissions now if
we're going to solve the global warming
problem we're going to need much better
green technology so there is a very
strong case for aggressive government
investment in basic R&D on new climate
friendly technologies and some of that
investment could be funded by permit
auctions and in some cases other
approaches such as technical standards
may be justified as a compliment to cap
and trade but not as a substitute okay
well you know fortunately I'm reasonably
confident that a cap-and-trade system
will be introduced in the next
administration because when Senator John
McCain introduced his cap and trade bill
he had as a supporter Barack Obama
thanks very much actually branstetter
Melissa Mickey young is a second year
student in the Heinz schools master of
science and public policy and management
program miss Yun has worked for various
environmental organizations including
the US Environmental Protection Agency
where she assisted in the development of
environmental sustainability criteria in
the office of site remediation
enforcement program evaluation and
coordination she earned her
undergraduate degree in environmental
science and policy graduating magna
laude from the University of Florida I
certainly was looking forward to your
remarks but after John's introduction
I'm really excited please join me in
welcoming Mickey young
well time is limited so unfortunately I
won't be able to cover all that they
made me out to be but I'd like to start
out with a reality check the next
president inherits an extensive list of
challenges when he takes office in
January national security is an issue
we're fighting two wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan the tarnished public opinion
of America abroad is impacting our
international relations the volatility
of food and energy prices puts pressure
on American households and has a
destabilizing effect on the developing
world we're experiencing an epidemic of
obesity and malnutrition and pollution
has become so ubiquitous throughout our
environment that multiple dangerous
chemicals can now be detected in nearly
every American's bloodstream even in
baby's umbilical cord blood and this is
just part of the shortlist still global
warming global climate change is the
most of overwhelming of our challenges
but this threat can also be seen as an
opportunity it's an opportunity to
reinvigorate our economy make us more
competitive in the global market and at
the same time improve our image as a
leader worldwide the threat of global
climate change can provide the impetus
for the next Industrial Revolution the
Green Revolution that's based on
innovations in the realm of green energy
alternative energy green building smart
planning and land use and lifecycle
product design I want to focus briefly
on one piece of the green revolution
alternative energy two of the most
promising prospects for renewable energy
or wind and solar because they're both
widely available
and they have the potential capacity to
satisfy our current and future energy
needs the main barriers to wind and
solar energy are related to their
intermittent nature and the prohibitive
costs as compared to fossil fuels but
government can help overcome these
problems in ways that go beyond
subsidizing the cost of inadequate
technologies an example of the type of
government action necessary to fight
global climate change through innovation
was when President Clinton in the year
2000 devoted 227 million dollars to the
national nanotechnology initiative to
fund research in nano enabled
technologies the fruits of this
investment are growing right here in
this building the melon Institute where
the chemistry department is home to
cutting-edge research in green chemistry
and solar technology and energy storage
this relatively small investment from
the government has propelled such
progress in this area that now we're
able to think not only about energy
independence as a nation but even the
possibility of energy independence for
every household the technology is so
promising that several spin-off
companies have been founded one great
example is Plex tronic which is a world
leader in the development of plastic
solar cells so my point here is that if
we keep at this work and if government
helps fund innovation we can develop
renewable energy technologies that are
safe simple and affordable and in the
process not only will we save ourselves
but there's the chance if we hurry that
emerging economies will be able to
advance their development without the
use of short-sighted energy strategies
like burning rain forests but I'd like
to reiterate that while alternative
energy is crucial there's a multitude of
other potential solutions that we need
to undertake
simultaneously like cap-and-trade
cutting our energy demand through
conservation and performance standards
improved in efficiency carbon
sequestration and whatever else we can
come up with that will help restore the
balance to our national park to our
natural carbon cycle and slow down that
spigot that dr. Morgan was talking about
relieve the pressure in that bathtub so
my advice to the next president is to
remember that this is our opportunity to
change the United States and the world
for the better it's his duty and
responsibility to act now and to act
boldly and not just to do something but
to do everything we can
now Thank You Mickey now we are going to
be taking questions and there's two
microphones out in the audience if you
wave your hand we will we will get those
to you and while we're waiting for the
first one I'm going to kick us off with
Granger I have a I have a question for
you in the engineering side we've been
for decades sort of since the age of
electricity first we're going to build
something and we get all excited as they
where we're going to get the power you
know it's like a well are we going to
plug it in we're going to get a battery
very much like we're going to get the
energy somewhere and a young engineering
student asked me the other day well how
should I think differently and I said
well for starters you know if you're
sitting in the Sun you'd better be a
power generator you know as black
top buildings you go on and on I said
just start thinking about generating
power from an orientation standpoint as
opposed to what are you going to get to
drive what you're building from an
engineering standpoint what changes in
mindset do we need to teach the
engineers that are coming along well we
need to get them thinking about
innovation and as a matter of fact the
Dean of engineering is about to put
together a a study group here at
Carnegie Mellon to figure out how we get
our engineering undergraduates of
thinking more about developing
innovative technologies because while
the sorts of cap and trade strategies
that we talked about will presumably
provide some market forces without
somebody out there figuring out the new
technologies that will respond you know
we're not going to get there we need
also of course substantially increased
resources for the development of these
new technologies a little later on Lee
and I may have a bit of an argument over
whether cap-and-trade is the right is
the only strategy to adopt but i'll save
that for later
yeah first question we have great when
you have a there we go run right over
here was the hero a a missed opportunity
Kyoto shall we have signed could you
hear that was the Kyoto Accord when we
were negotiating worldwide was that a
lost opportunity was that something we
should have signed what would have
changed to enable us to go on with it
should we assign the Kyoto Accords what
should we we just got a lot of
technology birpur actually we did sign
the Kyoto agreement we just failed to
ratify it and and in in in my opinion we
should have ratified it notwithstanding
its flaws and we should have then worked
to move to to fix those flaws as we
moved ahead we should have tried to fix
it on the fly rather than forgetting it
which was the strategy of the Bush
administration nonetheless I think at
this point the Kyoto Accord is basically
moot that is most of the countries that
agreed to targets are not going to meet
them there was never any agreement on
what the penalty would be for failing to
meet the targets I think one of the ways
we should have fixed it would to have
would have been to agree that the
penalty for failing to meet your target
would be to increase your investments in
low emitting technologies and measures
in proportion to the amount by which you
failed to meet the target in the
preceding period so that the punishment
would fit the crime as it were and would
lead to a remedy we didn't do any of
that we just walked away from it and it
was a big blow are walking away from it
to the world's attempt to make a
cooperative approach to this particular
problem nonetheless the question now is
what we should do
when the Kyoto Accord expires in 2012
what we need to do going forward and I
think there is real hope that with a new
administration coming in an early 2009
we will become full participants in the
process of deciding how to move forward
from 2012 in a way that will get the
world on a trajectory of emissions
declining after 2020 creator about a
dozen years ago I wrote an editorial in
the journal Science called managing
carbon from the bottom up which said
it's perfectly fine to be working on
trying to develop a single global regime
to which everyone will then agree and
and get on board but that it's very
unlikely that that any such agreement
reach now is going to be terribly
binding that what we really need is to
get a bunch of countries getting serious
about this problem and we ought to
divert at least a little bit of the
international negotiation to figuring
out how to merge a variety of evolving
strategies when you know the u.s. does
one thing and the Europeans do another
and so on to hold out the argument that
we're not going to do anything until
we've all gotten on board with a single
global regime I think would be a mistake
you look like you want to say something
just a quick quick Pro script out of
that I mean I I very much agree with
Granger supposition and in fact you
don't necessarily need a universal or a
global agreement or coordination to make
substantive progress a number of
proposals have been made in recent years
including some by David vector for a
focus group of countries including the
largest developing countries that can
meet together to talk seriously about
climate change reduction if you have
something that involves a very large
number of countries it can be very
difficult to come up with a deeply
meaningful agreement smaller numbers of
the right countries could make
substantial progress even in the absence
of them the next question is up here
wave your hands we can get a microphone
get set up for the next one yes sir ok
professor branstetter you were talking
about a safety valve associated with a
captain
great and one of the things that Tom
Friedman was talking about when gas was
at four dollars and a gallon three or
four weeks ago it seems was a present
having a program in place that would
keep four dollars as a minimum price for
gasoline I was just wondering if that
kind of negative safety valve also fits
into the kind of system that you
envision and in fact oh sorry and in
fact there are proposals that have been
debated in Congress suggesting the
creation of what we might call a carbon
fed a government agency that would
actually intervene in the permit market
to regulate the prices of permits so
that they don't go too high but that
they don't go too low it would operate a
little bit like Ben Bernanke and
monetary policy if the price drops too
low the carbon Fed steps in and buys up
permits until you get the price back up
to the desired level to produce strong
incentives for emissions mitigation and
if the price spikes then you have you
know a carbon Bernanke intervening to
try and mitigate some of those short run
impacts on industry so why don't we
start our interaction on this subject
what range I see a lot more questions
out there on the other so we'll take
another question in a moment but
carbon taxes are great I have no problem
with them the difficulty is it's a slow
and laborious process and there are is a
lot to be said for performance standards
that then allow some trading you could
do this on a sectoral basis you could
say you know every wires company every
power company that sells electricity to
an end customer must produce power that
is at or below some carbon intensity or
they need to buy credits or they need to
invest in developing that technology
cafe standards have worked pretty well
in the past for getting more efficient
motor vehicles on the road and the
effect of the sorts of carbon prices
that are people are now talking about in
the u.s. is politically viable will have
almost no effect on the driving and auto
choices of Americans and so while I got
no problem with implementing a cafe stay
I mean a cap-and-trade system also
thinks some sectoral specific
technologies or approaches to push
technology in these couple of sectors
where we know there's an enormous
problem could be a much faster route now
John I don't know if you have any views
on this or not well I agree and I tried
to mention this in my talk but I went by
it too quickly when I was listing the
ingredients of a strategy at the end I
said we need to put a price on carbon
but we need to supplement it with
measures in particular sectors that are
intractable in terms of how high the
carbon price has to get before they
would be adequately responsive and the
vehicle sector is one of those and coal
burning power generation is another
where we're not going to get a carbon
price plausibly in the next 15 years
that's high enough to motivate co2
capture and sequestration at
coal-burning power plants we need we
need to take yeah we need we need to
take additional measures to get that
done you know I just want to say before
we go to this question the other thing
we want to add into that is that I speak
with graduate students all the time and
i remember when i was in science and
engineering and graduate school and
people were like really interested in
the science or interest
the engineering and I have to say almost
to a person they they say they got into
it because they really want to change
the world they really want to solve a
lot of these problems and that
motivation is more than cap and tax and
money and economics and it's more than
just coming up with new innovation
because we love the science and
engineering but there is an entire
generation of people out there right now
who are totally motivated just to solve
these kinds of problems and I think
that's very heartening now we have
another question here what are the
relative merits of cap and trade versus
like a flat carbon tax that I also hear
mentioned economists like carbon taxes
for the most part we like them because
they tend to stabilize the cost that's
associated with a given level of
emissions and what we want to do is have
a costs that rises over time in a stable
and predictable way that's going to give
strong incentives to the economic system
and the rmv system to work on this
mitigation problem but taxes a carbon
taxes are taxes right so you recall the
debates last Wednesday night right i
mean one of the things that obama said
that surely people who aren't planning
to vote for him can agree with is that
nobody likes paying taxes and i think
there is some issue in terms of the
political sale ability of a carbon tax
as opposed to a cap-and-trade but here's
the thing you can get a lot of the
potential flexibility offered by a
carbon tax in a cap-and-trade system if
you get the design features right right
a carbon tax generates revenue that
could be used to do good things like
promote green R&D well if you auctioned
the permits in a cap-and-trade system
you get the revenue right a carbon tax
stabilizes the price of a unit of GHG
emissions well if you have a carbon fed
or a safety valve on the upside and a
price floor on the downside you can
stabilize those prices in the context of
a cap-and-trade system and the other
thing that you can build into a
cap-and-trade system that will be harder
to incorporate into a carbon tax would
be credits for
things like carbon sequestration
technologies so I would have I have come
around to seeing you know the carbon tax
and the cap-and-trade system is being
points on a continuum of potential
policy movements and as long as we get
to some point on the continuum that's
within a reasonable range I think it'll
be a vast improvement or what currently
exists hey I've been passed a question
for Mickey Mickey someone would like you
to discuss the blog there was a student
blog right Nikki this should be one
right there okay discuss the blog okay
well there's been some discussion about
whether the economy has overtaken the
issue of global warming in this
presidential election and whether the
political interest is there to deal with
it anymore now that people's pocketbooks
or their largest concern I don't really
have the answer i mean like i said the
economy and the housing crisis and the
financial system collapses all at the
front of our minds right now but this is
a problem that's not going to go away
and it is something that the next
president is going to have to deal with
and I think it's still a factor in the
way people are going to vote in the
election right here I'm not convinced
that carbon sequestration has been
anywhere close to being proven the coal
companies want us to believe that this
is going to really work well and from
what I understand it's both very
expensive and very difficult to do and
I've heard a couple plants experimental
plants
closed is that true I mean we really
have something here that's going to work
or is it just some propaganda to keep
the coal industry in this okay well I
last question I'll start and John may
want to add first first the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change did a very thorough look at this
technology this is the same group that
has met three times now to produce these
ant these extensive reviews of climate
science and its impacts and actually a
member of my faculty was asked to write
the technical summary for that report
the answer is this technology will work
and no it won't be extraordinarily
expensive but it will require carbon
prices up around forty dollars a ton of
co2 or more and at the moment the
political discussions are all we can't
possibly have carbon prices above about
twelve or fifteen dollars a ton because
it's politically unacceptable so there
is that problem the issue is that all
the technology exists today at
commercial scale so me for example the
way that we get a carbon dioxide for our
coke and pepsi is by scrubbing co2 out
of the exhaust streams of power plants
we have gasification systems now they're
not being used for this purpose but
there are hundreds of these things
running all around the world in the
chemical industry Eastman Chemical in
Kentucky has a couple of them running
that they've been running for years and
we got a lot of locations around we have
locations around the world where there
is co2 being injected deep underground
when I said a lot most of them are
pretty small but there are some that are
comparable in scale for example off the
coast of Norway in the slight nur field
there's a natural gas reservoir natural
gas often comes with co2 intermixed
they're separating the co2 andrey
injecting it deep under the seabed the
same is going on in a BP project in
algeria all the pieces exist but the
problem is we've got to start actually
doing this so we can
down the learning curve because if we
don't there are others around who are
going to do it first mean as I was
joking too John earlier the the images
that we're going to develop the
technology and then solve China's call
problem by handing it to them I'm
increasingly thinking the technology
transfer maybe in the opposite direction
you do something what and identity the
debate given what my colleagues said
about about standards so you look at you
know at one level if we can all agree
that a cap-and-trade system is a good
place to start I'm inclined to just
declare victory and move on but the
discussion that you know a price of
forty dollars a time is is politically
unfeasible but that alternative
strategies which might actually have
higher costs are feasible because the
costs are less evident or transparent is
something that you know some economists
would take exception to now I realize
that the exact cost calculations depend
on one's assumptions they depend on the
model and we don't really know at this
point what they will cost but I think
the reality is that whatever we do it's
going to cost us something as a society
and the question of whether we as a
society will be willing to pay those
costs is ultimately not an economic
question it's almost a philosophical
question and that question is not altima
tlie going to be answered by us it's
going to be answered by you I mean
Franklin Delano Roosevelt said to our
grandparents generation your generation
has a rendezvous with destiny well so
does this generation such as well now
I'm just a quick comment it'll be
choose I was hoping you'd say something
jacek two sentences wind nuclear are two
examples of carbon free generation that
will be about the same price as CCS and
so yeah it takes about forty dollars a
ton to get there but we're already
putting in lots of wind around and we're
subsidizing it to do it but you know
half or so of our electricity comes from
coal I don't know how to get there from
here without using this technology well
two weeks from tomorrow is the is an
election day and we will have a new
president elect and so I've arranged for
each of you to be able to speak in the
president elects ear for just you know
30 40 50 seconds you know under a minute
one big idea one single idea that you
want this president elect to hear I'm
gonna start with you Mickey well the big
idea is that there is no single solution
and then it's going to take a holistic
multi-faceted approach and we need to do
something right now not just something
but but everything get the wheels moving
and really take this issue seriously
thank you Lee well it's probably no
surprise cap and trade
but the right cap and trade okay that's
the right place to start and there's
going to be a heck of a political fight
to get there we want to avoid pushes to
exempt industries right we want to avoid
the push to have free allocation forever
and I think it would be useful to have a
safety valve for a carbon fit right
Granger well we got a mess in the
economy and one way to work our way out
of it is to start building stuff and
hiring people to do it before you start
spending money you need to talk with
folks who've done some careful analysis
you don't want to waste money but
there's a lot of things we could start
doing now that involve putting concrete
in the ground and bending steel and we
need to start yeah my advice would be
very similar to Granger's the key point
I would make is that although the
economy must now be very high on the
national agenda the link between the
energy issue the climate issue and the
economy is an intense one and the fact
is the risks to our economy are far
greater from neglecting the climate
problem than from solving it if we solve
the climate problem we will actually
reap a variety of economic benefits
including new jobs new technology a
redirection of some economic activity
far more than a loss of economic
activity and we will avoid immense
economic damages which we face from the
failure to address the climate problem
well I'm a little shocked myself to
realize that I oh please applause this
always
well I'm a little while I was scheduling
those little little little blurbs into
the president elects ear actually
scheduled one for myself and I'm a
little surprised to be saying I'm
paraphrasing Muhammad Ali to the
president-elect but he always said he I
can't do it like he did or does but you
need more than the skill ya gotta have
the will and that's that's really where
we are now before we have before I have
a few announcements before that first of
all let me thank my panelists dr. John
Holdren dr. Granger Morgan dr. Lee
Branstetter and Mickey young
let us think let us also thank Teresa
Heinz the Heinz award John Heinz the
third School of Public Policy and
management of course carnegie mellon
university
and as for the announcements they are to
number one please join us for a
reception immediately afterward and
number two would the last person out
please not forget to turn off the lights
thank you very much